la primera visita de una autoridad
francesa desde el inicio de la guerra
tras su llegada a kiev en tren desde
polonia cat cinco lonas empezó su
jornada en lucha escenario de decenas de
asesinatos civiles descubiertos tras la
retirada de las fuerzas rusas de la zona
a finales de marzo
allí katrin colonna ha rendido homenaje
a las víctimas y ha insistido en la
solidaridad de francia con el pueblo
ucraniano
hay que decir que esto nunca tendría que
haber pasado y no tiene que volver a
empezar les deseamos lo mejor que la paz
vuelva lo más rápido posible francia
está a su lado al lado de sus aliados
para que la paz vuelva lo antes posible
entre el programa de este lunes de la
nueva ministra de asuntos exteriores de
francia encuentro con su homólogo
ucraniano dmitro culeba y con el
presidente volodymyr selenski y entrega
de material de seguridad civil de
camiones de bomberos y de ambulancias a
las autoridades ucranianas la visita
llega en un contexto tenso entre parís y
kiev que reprocha a francia no hacer
suficiente para el pueblo ucraniano por
un lado por no usar el término genocidio
para calificar las atrocidades de butch
a como sí ha hecho el presidente de eeuu
joe biden y por otro por responder a las
aspiraciones ucranianas de entrar en la
unión europea con la propuesta de una
comunidad política europea cuyo objetivo
sería acercar a bruselas a los países
que aspiran a entrar en el bloque una
respuesta decepcionante para ucrania que
quisiera obtener el estatuto de
candidato oficial a la unión europea
antes de finales de junio